wwe summerslam is tomorrow night at a
legion stadium the main event includes
wwe champion bobby lashley taking on the
legend goldberg i spoke to bobby earlier
about his big bout
the almighty wwe champion
bobby
lastly
he is the star of monday night raw he is
the wwe champion he is the almighty he
is bobby lashley bobby welcome to the
show my first question for you buddy is
where are you going to go tomorrow night
here in las vegas where are you going to
go after you beat bill goldberg where's
the celebration tomorrow night i think
that's the greatest question right there
um it's got to be some kind of after
party you know
in vegas there's always great after
parties everywhere so um i know a couple
of the old concierge that i've used
before in some of my fights have
contacted me so um we might have to go
somewhere we're gonna go somewhere we're
gonna celebrate a little bit but yes we
are we're going to celebrate when you
win tomorrow night yeah absolutely
lastly
i'm kind of geeking out one because i'm
talking to you but secondly uh over your
right shoulder there can you show us the
hardware can you give us a nice view of
the hardware yes
do you travel with that everywhere you
go because if i was wwe champion like
you i would be that would be my
all-access pass to anything oh i can't
get into this club i'm the champion what
about this
yeah man um you know i keep it
everywhere i go it's kind of hard going
through the airports at times because as
soon as it goes through the security
because i can't check it so as soon as i
go through the security you always see
the security guy kind of like lean in
and it's like hey you know it's
it's the title don't worry about it no
now tomorrow night with the match
against goldberg he's he's doing
something different this time he's i
feel like he's out to prove something
for his son gage and gage has been a
little bit involved with things building
up to summerslam what are you gonna do
tomorrow night if his son decides to
somehow get involved in this match
his son just needs to he needs to keep
out of grown folks business first of all
and and i understand that he has his
motivation in helping out his son or
having him
see him with the title but i got a son
too my son's 13 years old and my son's
been stoked since i've had this so the
last thing i want to do is lose it
because my son's going to be
disappointed so i'm i could care less
about what his motivations are it's all
about my motivations i'm a huge
wrestling fan and i first went to
summerslam back in 1990. i was a little
kid was in philadelphia it was
earthquake against hulk hogan in the
ultimate warrior against rickroot in a
steel cage just it was an amazing night
so i'm looking forward to going back to
summerslam tomorrow night but before you
got into business did you go to any big
pay-per-view events i was a military
brat so army brat so we traveled all
over the world and i never had an
opportunity to do one go to a concert or
go to any kind of sporting event at all
whatsoever
since i've grown
i've actually been able to go through a
few football games a few baseball games
and basketball games i've yet to go to a
concert the jonas brothers the jonas
brothers are in concert this weekend so
if you want to when it's all said and
done you and i could go see the jonas
brothers together
hey man i i would be up for it i heard
they put on a great show so i'm all
about a show
go to jonas brothers i can't wait for
this i was
[Laughter]
it's tomorrow night as i mentioned i was
at summerslam back in 1990 and here's a
picture that's my brother there
with every piece of merchandise
available look at me behind him
all stone face not one single piece of
merchandise my parents didn't buy me
anything that's all right they they got
your tickets that's true they got me
tickets classic summerslam music playing
this is awesome look at that
that is so cool there are still tickets
available for wwe summerslam happening
tomorrow at allegion stadium
[Music]